May is mental health awareness month and
Intermountain Health the sponsors of
this next segment are here to help us
refocus on our mental well-being join us
joining us now is Leticia Morgan with
Intermountain Health welcome to the show
thank you for having me first off you're
wearing green you gave me my green pen
because green is the official color for
mental health awareness absolutely where
do we start where do you how do you even
start working on your mental health well
first you have to identify that you may
be struggling with something or someone
in your family or friends may say hey
I've noticed something different about
you lately so doing a self-assessment is
really key to assessing your mental
health just like you do with your
physical health what are some signs
maybe you lose interest in things you
normally like what are signs that
someone is struggling absolutely so you
lose interest in things you're not doing
the things that you used to do you've
become withdrawn or you're finding
yourself feeling anxious a lot more than
often and so you're like wow I need to
do a self-assessment here things are
changing so being in tune with your body
you have to be aware of these signs that
are happening within yourself and the
friends as well well you and I were
talking before the segment started about
trauma and people think I haven't had
experience any trauma we've all
experienced trauma over the past three
or four years what is the trauma we've
experienced and how do we deal with it
so first the biggest one is the pandemic
but also we've the shootings that have
occurred when we're seeing these things
happen we subconsciously react to them
you know we're more aware of where we're
going we're more aware of exits and so
you want to do a self-assessment you
want to check your breathing a lot of
times that's the first thing that seems
to be affected and it's like oh maybe I
am experiencing some trauma people don't
like to go on crowds now and so just
doing that self-assessment saying it's
something changing am I starting to
sweat more am I getting hot in these
situations we mentioned breathing I
think that is so key breathing
techniques are there some habits I
practice gratitude I think that helps
with mental health are there certain
habits we can do to improve our mental
health absolutely so gratitude
journaling
um also mindfulness so doing those
breathing exercises and thinking about
things that you're grateful for and
setting the tone for your day saying hey
I'm going to have a positive day despite
what happens and really striving for the
positive and looking for that positive
yes what are some resources because
someone says okay I do all that stuff
but it's not helping or I'm still
struggling what are some resources that
you offer that people can turn to so at
Intermountain you can always contact
your primary care provider and they will
link you to a mental health professional
but if you're not with Intermountain you
can also dial 988 and they will link you
to a professional that can help you with
what you're struggling with I gotta wrap
it up but let's say someone's watching
or maybe someone's here in the studio is
struggling and they don't know what to
do what would your advice to them be the
first thing to do is ask someone it may
not be your provider it could be your
friend because that's the first step is
saying hey I'm having an issue and so
just asking and reaching out for help so
that can be to a mental health
professional that could be to your
primary care provider that could be to
your friend or someone in your family I
love it Leticia thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it thank you
all right thank you to Intermountain
Health for sponsoring this segment for
more information visit
intermountainnv.org
and let's send it over to you Jillian